from Zack Snyder and his accurately
named production company comes the
blockbuster that United the world's two
biggest superheroes and invited everyone
else Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
get ready for the Battle of the century
between critics and fans that had the
movie's most rabid supporters sending
out death threats while its harshest
critics refuse to admit that anything
about it was cool even though you'd be
lying he thought this wasn't awesome
and this wasn't ridiculous why does the
cyanide add Warner Brothers needed a
surefire mega hit to keep pace with the
MCU now they're pairing a screenwriter
who once said Batman vs Superman is
where you go when you admit to yourself
you've exhausted all possibilities and a
director who once said Batman could get
raped in prison that can happen in my
movie really strange choices in
retrospect you were promised the dawn of
the Justice League and they delivered an
email attachment as the DC extended
universe kicks off with a folder of
low-res QuickTime videos the design the
logos leaving audiences with a cool new
Batman movie trapped inside a boring
convoluted Superman sequel trapped
inside whatever cartoon Lex Luthor is
robbed oh yeah hi and I'm no no what am
I I suppose I say the Man of Steel you
know and fear has returned yeah and even
he's not sold on the whole Superman gig
Superman
witness the hero who once stood for
truth justice in the American Way stand
for booty
moping and wondering why even bothers as
the film's main character has nothing to
do but silently look constipated get
horrible pep talks from his parents be
anything they need you won't be none of
it suck at his job was then and refused
to fight back against his toughest
opponent yet cable news
Superman was involved in the planning of
this attack is not a hero must there be
a Superman stop scallion book an
interview smile go to carpool karaoke
and sing at Five For Fighting song i'm
more than a bird i'm more than a plane
my god he's still a beefcake those abs
are so good you won't even notice how
fake those eggs are watch zack snyder
prove once and for all that the hero he
really wanted to make movies about is
this guy or at least his weird murdery
fanfic version
Ben Affleck shines as Batman who's one
part CrossFit bro
one part Superman one part Tony Stark
one part Arkham video game and one part
actual bat real while the world's
greatest detective finally gets to do
some actual detective work as the actor
we all assumed would be the worst part
of this movie is by far the best part of
this movie oh also everything Wonder
Woman did was really cool sorry that
seems kind of tacked on and that place
but you know so was she she would you I
thought she was here
of course she's with you he's in an
e-mail like half an hour ago remember
watch The Dark Knight grow to hate
Superman for clear obvious reasons while
Superman grows to hate Batman back
because Lex Luthor hired someone to kill
a criminal Batman branded before he put
him in prison so that when Clark kid
refused to cover the local football team
and investigated the Gotham vigilante
instead he would conclude that look I
don't have time to explain the whole
thing and we just Rolexes plan real
quick okay let's see here right CIA yeah
let's see okay I don't even remember
that bar oh yeah there it is okay uh
step nine a you know I forgot about that
bar pee in a jar man this is complicated
you don't have to throw everything but
the kitchen sink into your evil plan
and there's the sink you've been waiting
since you were a kid to see these two
icons go toe-to-toe well keep waiting
for two King hours through boring
congressional hearings let me say at the
outset that I'm grateful to our witness
so much journalism why aren't we
covering this and a semesters worth of
intro to philosophy lectures God is
all-powerful
it cannot be on to finally get the
awesome fight you were promised in the
title that ends after just eight minutes
because their moms have the same name I
know BAM it's hung up on his dead
parents but come on she has the power to
wipe out the entire human race and if we
believe there's even a 1% chance that he
is our enemy we have to take it as an
absolute having a mom changes none of
that motivation no matter what her name
is you can write all the essays you want
convincing yourself this was brilliant
then again dumb is a one syllable word
that covers it pretty well so suit up
for a bill that was so highly
anticipated it could never have lived up
to the high that had to deliver the
fight fans have wanted to see on the big
screen for decades address the
controversy around Man of Steel make
enough money to compete with Marvel be a
sequel to Man of Steel and a Batman so a
movie pandered a jar of pee enthusiasts
formed the Justice League introduced
Wonder Woman the flash Aquaman cyborg
Lex Luthor parademons tombs day
Steppenwolf the death of Superman whose
idea was it to cram all this into one
movie they just burned through like six
movies worth of good material uh but
early Suicide Squad looks pretty cool
though right
starring fat flick forever last son of
crapped on lady in the water
Jeremy's iron hector salamanca teenage
mutant abomination lord of the rings'
cave troll max landis worst product
placement ever what the hell is even
happening here had to ask like ten
harcore DC fans and even some of them
didn't know Xena warrior cameo a
Democratic senator from Kentucky sure
why not
tonight a comedian died in Gotham Martha
Wayne and Martha Kent oh now I get it
nope still dumb fans V Batman V Superman
the critics the other fans the
executives V Zack Snyder the
expectations can't do them all justice
how come dad never left Kansas you let
him die in a tornado remember wish this
honest trailer was even longer well then
click the box on the left to watch the
Batman V Superman honest trailer
Ultimate Edition which is even longer
than the fight between Batman and
Superman it's uncut and uncensored
filled with even more jokes and rants we
tacked on to get you to watch it twice
just like PBS did and don't forget
starting this Thursday we will be
broadcasting live from San Diego
comic-con for screen junkies central
featuring celebrity editions of all your
favorite este shows that you truly will
not want to miss so click the Box on the
right to register and watch for free in
Mother Russia Pokemon catches you
Pokemon go is sky act you rusty potato I
will stab you with a moldy spoon
I am score Atticus prepare to suckle
from the teat of defeat